Від самого народження й дотепер вони постійно разом.
Брати-близнюки Григорій та Олексій Кулачинські -
одні з наймолодших рятувальників України.
Вони настільки звикли йти пліч-о-пліч,
що навіть працюють в одній пожежній частині.
Щоправда завжди в різних караулах.
Нам навіть за це легше,
адже якщо би ми були в одній зміні і, наприклад,
хтось з нас зайшов у задимлене середовище, то було б морально тяжко.
Ну не знаєш, як там, що там.
Починаєш переживати.
І це буде сильніше душити психологічно.
Своє "хрещення пожежника" брати-близнюки пройшли минулого літа.
Ще курсантами вони рятували людей та розбирали завали
після ракетного удару Росії по Вінниці 14 липня.
Тоді загинули 27 людей, майже двісті постраждали.
Тоді залучалися 100 курсантів та 10 офіцерів.
Це перша така складна подія, яка була.
Спочатку було не по собі, а потім змогли взяти себе в руки.
Коли приїхали, то знову почалася тривога.
Нас всіх курсантів загнали в підвал, там сховище було.
В будинку. Ми посиділи хвилин 12,
потім нас випустили, ми пішли далі розбирати конструкції,
діставати людей, рятувати.
Після завершення навчання брати Кулачинські
влаштувалися в одну з пожежних частин Одеси.
Нині обидва - командири відділення.
Посада відповідальна, тим паче в Одесі -
місті, яке регулярно зазнає ракетних атак з боку Росії.
Командири відділення відповідають за все на пожежі,
керують відділенням.
Проводить розвідку, керує відділенням,
Це як найбільш досвідчена людина на пожежі,
яка є командиром свого відділення.
І хоча вони наймолодші рятувальники регіону -
досвіду мають вже чимало. Адже війна не лишила часу
на поступову адаптацію в роботі.
Брати одразу почали працювати в надскладних умовах.
Приміром, після кожного удару Росії по Одесі
бодай один із братів працює на місці руйнувань.
Так було й в ніч на 14 серпня,
коли росіяни поцілили у супермаркет.
Це був магазин "Фоззі". Дуже багато часу ми там працювали.
Ми виїхали ще вночі під час тривоги,
ми трохи, як сказати, очікували,
потім почали вже повне розгортання, почали працювати,
гасити пожежу. І так до самого ранку ми працювали.
Десь о годині 8-9 ми вже були в частині.
Це лише наша частина, там деякі ще працювали.
Проте найглибше й найболючіше війна вплинула на братів
не в професійному житті, а в особистому.
На початку літа вітчим, якого хлопці любили,
як рідного батька, загинув неподалік Бахмута.
Наші батьки захищають Україну, були в місті Бахмут.
Та при виконанні своїх обов'язків батько…
Під час розмінування міни він був командиром саперної групи.
При розмінуванні був обстріл, він загинув під час вибуху.
Це найближча людина.
Він хоч і недовго з нами жив, спілкувався частіше.
Рідко бачилися, бо вони були на лінії нульовій в Бахмуті.
Він нам дав те, що не дав рідний батько.
Дав упору, дав те, що повинен давати рідний батько.
А мама братів і нині на передовій.
Хлопці кажуть: вже звикли до того, що мати на війні,
адже у війську вона ще з часів проведення АТО.
Там і познайомилася зі своїм чоловіком.
Вони дуже багато вже пройшли міст.
І останнє місце якраз там, де загинув батько.
Вони разом працювали, разом служили.
Тобто на гарячій лінії в таких умовах вони познайомилися.
Потім їх офіційно вже розписав зампотил по-військовому.
І так були одружені.
Тяжко їй, ми бачимо це, розуміємо, що без нього їй тяжко,
що вона не може без нього нічого зробити.
Раніше в неї було плече, на яке вона могла покластися,
яке знаходиться дуже близько, а зараз в неї немає такої змоги.
Та попри усі випробування долі брати не втратили бажання
допомагати й рятувати. Навпаки, кажуть, ще більше почали цінувати
свою роботу й підтримку одне одного.
Ми працюємо для того, щоб допомагати людям,
які не можуть надати собі допомогу: під час воєнного стану,
під час всього, що твориться від цієї війни.
Морально воно на нас не дуже впливає,
не робить з нас якихось слабих, або ще щось.
Ми працюємо, тому що ми розуміємо, що це наша робота,
що це наш обов'язок і треба нам це робити.
Ми самі вибрали цю роботу, тому так і працюємо.
І попри війну будують плани на майбутнє.
Нині брати займаються вступом до університету,
аби в майбутньому стати керівниками рятувальних підрозділів.
Так, як хотів Віталій - вітчим, який замінив хлопцям батька.